la visite à tahiti du président de la
république titre à sauf le général de
gaulle entreprend la dernière étape de
son voyage miroir et le périmètre
d'expérimentations nucléaires où il
assistera si la météo le permet à
l'explosion d'une bombe à la dernière
journée à tahiti
c'est maintenant là bas le début de la
matinée a donné l'occasion au président
de la république de remercier les
habitants de l'île pour leur hospitalité
et notre récit aux populations de la
polynésie
le salut de la métropole pour l'entendre
des maires et des chefs de district
avait fait jusqu'à 1000 km en goélette à
travers le pacifique
c'est cette belle maison basse de style
polynésien au toit de hand à nous et aux
murs de bambou sous les cocotiers et au
bord du lagon qui pour deux jours fut la
présidence de la république à ses hôtes
le chef de l'état a promis la
modernisation de la polynésie rappeler
les preuve de patriotisme données par la
population au cours des deux guerres
mondiales conclues en dix ans la france
envers ce territoire de grands devoirs
et un élégant pira le chef de l'état dit
aussi l'importance pour la nation des
installations du centre d'études
nucléaires de mururoa où il atterrira
dans quelques heures nous sommes at il
dit en train de réaliser une puissance
moderne destinée non à dominer mais à
dissuader les autres de nous attaquer au
franc ainsi les plus grandes chances de
paix qui soit paisible mur euros à est
un atoll en forme d'anneau allongée de
27 le mettre sur 12
c'est là que le général de gaulle guidés
par le ministre des armées monsieur
messmer et le ministre chargé de la
recherche scientifique monsieur
peyrefitte visitera le lieu de
l'explosion
engin atomique destinée à la prochaine
expérience sera placée en altitude
accroché à ce ballon lancé au dernier
moment
et si le temps est favorable tout est
donc prêt pour le cas où les conditions
météorologiques permettront l'expérience
tout c'est à dire le poste de contrôle
avancé le blockhaus que nous voyons ici
à l'intérieur duquel sont placés des
instruments de mesure et des caméras le
bâtiment de contrôle est aussi à pied
d'oeuvre
c'est la rance bâtiment de soutien
logistique entièrement étanche comme
d'ailleurs le croiseur de grâce
spécialement équipé pour évoluer dans
les zones radioactives
le de grasse que nous voyons ici et à
bord duquel prendra place le général de
gaulle dont la date de retour n'a pas
pour l'instant était l'objet de
modifications
l'expérience et je le rappelle prévu
pour demain
en principe